So the day after the El Paso, Texas Shooting
Fox News not only avoided
telling us the shooter's name, which I'm in
favor of, and I do as well.
They also didn't tell us about the shooter
leaving and anti-immigrant White Nationalists
Manifesto.
They told us there was a manifesto, but for
our own protection to avoid glorifying the
shooter, to avoid glorifying the motives of
the shooter, I guess they were not going to
publicize the content of the manifesto.
And then yesterday, Fox and friends, literally
parrots, one of the manifestos talking points
of verbatim as fact about a so-called Hispanic
invasion.
Complete clown, Brian Kilmeade called it a
quote, fact that there is an invasion of immigrants
coming from Latin America.
Now, just as a reminder, all of our stories
this week, even tangentially related to the
shooting had been demonetized by youtube.
Uh, so please consider supporting us directly
with a membership on our website.
Join pacman.com this is important stuff to
cover a youtube demonetizing all of it because
it is apparently I'm not in line with the
whims of advertisers.
So this is what the shooter, uh, said in the
manifesto that they hid from us.
And then here is Fox News itself repeating
that exact same talking point,
uh, with the, with the president has during
his two and a half years is a major problem
at the border, which was not his doing unless
you want to blame President Obama for the
unaccompanied minors that stream through here
in 2014 when you have over 110,000 people
coming a month over a million, uh, last year
and then well over a million this year.
If you use the term is as an invasion that's
not anti Hispanic.
It's a fact.
If the Russians will come in through Alaska,
through Canada, the president will be using
the same language, but it's the fact that's
happening at the border.
If you talk to people who are apolitical at
the border, people want to look at the words,
each offense to infested, invests, infested,
or for your back.
And look at the, with the president saying,
this is the shooter's manifesto.
Presented by someone with more media savvy,
able to sort of round out and Polish these
ideas.
Brian Kilmeade and no Trump would not call
Russian immigration and invasion.
It's funny that Brian killed me to actually
suggest that on Saturday as news of the shooting
broke, Fox News interrupted, it's fear-mongering
on the Texas border to report an anti-immigrant
shooting, uh, on the Texas border.
Here they are repeating the same talking points
that the shooter included in their manifesto.
Are they this dense like do they not understand
that this is what they're doing or are they
doing it on purpose?
Like is it actually more insidious than even
we might think?
Is it, you know, we don't want to ascribe
to malice that which we can explain adequately
with ignorance, but I don't know that ignorance
actually explains this.
It actually may be malice.
Fox News and the white nationalist shooter
are on the same page.
We have an invasion of Hispanic immigrants.
Let me give you a nice little throwback refresher
of who Brian Kilmeade is.
By the way, for those not familiar with them,
this is a video of Brian kill me.
10 years ago, basically doing eugenics on
Fox News.
Take a look.
I do.
I'm just amazed that they thought about doing
this study in the, but they, by interviewing
people in the set 1970s in the 1980s little
bit, it's 50 and they see that, that they
keep it together.
I find this a, I find this somewhat limited,
the Finns and Swedes to come up with something
that that's a we are, we're, we're, we're,
we keep marrying other species and other ethnics
and other, I mean the sweetened dementia,
see the problem resetting the suites have
a pure genes like marry other sweets because
that's the role.
Finland fins are American to the fit so they
have a pure society in America we marry everybody
marry Italians and Irish money does not apply,
not apply to us.
Pro White Eugenics on Fox News.
They are part of the problem and then I want
to bring it around sort of full circle.
Part of the problem is that they're simply
xenophobes and they are cow toweling and placating
xenophobes and the president of the United
States is doing the same thing and these actions
are having real world impacts like what we
saw over the weekend.
But there's another reason why massive corporate
media would even push this narrative altogether.
And it's really important to understand this
is the same thing as the immigrants are stealing
your jobs stuff.
When people are mad at Hispanics for our problems,
they aren't mad at corporations.
The real reasons that wages are stagnant and
the middle class is shrinking and all of this
is not Hispanics.
It's huge.
Corporations taking advantage of everything
from immigration to tax law while they foam
at fighting between the lower and lower middle
and middle class period.
You've got to understand that and it's important,
you know, when we covered these things, the
shooting in and of itself as a discreet and
specific event is important to talk about
the motivations of the shooter and media coverage
of the shooting are extraordinarily important
to talk about.
But when we step back for a second and we
look more broadly at immigration, and I've
been trying to do this over the last year
and a half, you have to understand that corporations
of which big corporate media is apart, have
a specific incentive to get people mad at
each other instead of at them because they
are the ones really benefiting.
It's the corporations that benefit from undocumented
immigrant labor, but yet they are very happy
to have you believing the problem is a Hispanic
immigrant from Latin America who just wants
a better life for his family.
They are not actually the problem.
This is all part of that same narrative, really,
really important that we don't have sort of
lose sight
of that.